[Musica]
stavo preparando i pop corn alle 2 del
mattino che è l'unico momento della
giornata è quale sono produttiva e
metterli stava facendo mentre stavo
aspettando che esplode essere tutti
quanti mi sono accorta che non scoppiano
tutti insieme
all'inizio quando lei scaldati un
pochino ce n'è qualcuno timido qualche
innovatore che inizi a scoppiare
poi arriva un momento nel quale sembra
che scoppino tutti insieme e poi ci sono
dei ritardatari degli ultimi arrivati e
siccome sono io ho pensato come fare un
grafico di questa cosa facciamo così
sull'asse orizzontale
mettiamo il tempo prendiamo i due minuti
che ci vogliono più o meno a cuocere i
pop corn e li dividiamo in tanti
intervalli contiamo 19 i primi 10
secondi i secondi 10 secondi dai 10 ai
20 e avanti così e sull'asse verticale
mettiamo quanti pop corn sono scoppiati
in quell'intervallo di tempo che cosa
succede per se vogliamo graphicar e
quello che dicevamo prima all'inizio c'è
soltanto qualche un po più coraggioso
degli altri che esplode poi arriva un
momento nel quale scoppiano tutti questo
sarebbe quello che chiamiamo il picco
del grafico e poi pian piano i pop corn
si calma lo diciamo in china sono
scoppiati tutti quanti
la statistica è l'arte di trovare ordine
nel caos
un altro esempio se lanciamo un dado un
milione di volte le volte che verrà 1 e
le volte che verrà sei saranno più o
meno lo stesso sarà più o meno un
milione diviso 6
ecco tuttavia ogni lancio di dado non
sappiamo esattamente che cosa verrà
fuori
facciamo un po come se ci fosse qualcosa
che si nasconde dietro a tutti gli
eventi che li governa da dietro le
quinte ma che viene fuori soltanto
quando ce ne sono un bel po diamo un
pochino più a fondo
un esempio dal mondo della fisica adesso
secondo ai fisici un gas un area che
riempie una stanza è una serie di
molecole di palline piccolissime che
viaggiano per la stanza e girano a
velocità piuttosto elevate non è
possibile per noi tracciare dove sta
andando ogni singola pallina perché in
questa stanza soltanto ce ne sono di di
miliardi è impossibile stare dietro a
tutte è impossibile ricordarsi quale è
andata dove e quale sta andando a quale
velocità
tuttavia se noi prendiamo la velocità
media delle palline se diciamo in media
più o meno in quanto stanno andando
vediamo che se quanto più le palline
vanno veloci tanto più il nostro gas
sarà caldo
cominciamo allora vedere un tema
ricorrente no se non possiamo guardare
che cosa sto facendo il singolo evento
ma se guardiamo a un insieme in tutta la
sua interezza a un insieme di palline
c'è qualche proprietà che viene fuori in
questo caso la temperatura una cosa
molto concreta noi fisici per tutta la
storia della fisica
abbiamo cercato di trovare delle leggi
esatte credo che in assoluto la più
famosa sia quella che chiamiamo f uguale
m a
cioè la forza è uguale alla massa per
l'accelerazione che dice questo se io ho
un corpo come può essere questo
la
accelerazione che posso imprimergli
quanto posso farlo accelerare sarà la
forza che gli do diviso per la sua massa
e questa è una legge universale che vale
per qualsiasi oggetto non è una legge
che vediamo fare solo se proviamo su
tanti oggetti ecco tuttavia non tutte le
leggi funzionano così con alcune alcune
non sono così severe diciamo come questa
est è uguale a me ha alcune sono un po
più gentili un po più nascosta ecco è un
po per capire la statistica direi che è
un po come se la legge dice se ai vari
lanci di da di o alle varie particelle
per la stanza dice guardate io non so
chi di voi vuole fare che cosa
non so quale scelte volete fare ma alla
fine dei conti deve venir fuori che
tanti lanci sono venuti fuori uno quanti
lanci sono venuti fuori 6
organizzatevi voi non lo so
e a loro volta i lanci di da di ogni
singola lancio di dado è come se dicesse
dopo di me ci sono infiniti altri lanci
se io vengo fuori uno ce ne sara
qualcuno che viene fuori 6 no io faccio
quello che mi pare e per qualche cosmica
ragione
queste due cose si non si annullano però
si completano a vicenda
ecco questo concetto è alla base di
tutta la statistica
tant'è che ha un nome piuttosto
altisonante diciamo e la legge dei
grandi numeri
se lanciamo una moneta una volta ci
tiene testa ci viene croce ma quell
unico evento non ci può dire nulla sul
comportamento sulla legge che governa il
comportamento del lancio della moneta
perché abbiamo soltanto un evento non ne
abbiamo abbastanza per fare statistica
non ne abbiamo abbastanza per trovare
ordine
dietro al caos del lancio di una moneta
stabile sarà lanciamo un milione di
volte
iniziamo a vedere che un po di volte
viene testa un po di volta viene croce e
allora sappiamo che la probabilità si
avvicina al 50 per cento
il modo matematico di dirlo è che se
abbiamo un insieme di eventi
man mano che l'insieme di eventi tende
all'infinito man mano che ce ne sono
sempre di più la media degli eventi
tenderà alla media della distribuzione
questo non aiuta per rimorchiare alle
feste l'ho provato nel modo sbagliato
pensate che ci sia
sono molto attirato dalla statistica
perché mi fa pensare che ci sia sempre
un ordine
dietro al caos in particolare questo
esempio delle monete a una connessione
personale per me fra ci sono delle volte
in cui anch'io fisico devo arrendermi
quando dovevo scegliere che facoltà fare
che triennale scegliere era indecisa fra
fisica matematica qualcosa di matematico
rigoroso scientifico oppure rende cisa
fra un lato più artistico le mie opzioni
erano filosofia el accademia di teatro
non riesco a immaginare niente di più
diverso proprio ed era così indecisa che
ho deciso di lanciare una monetina a voi
scelto che testa doveva essere fisica
matematica e croce l'altro ma
ripensandoci considerando quanto mi sono
stressato forse avrebbe dovuto invertire
comunque ho lanciato un unico lancio
niente statistica stavolta ed è venuto
testa quindi immagino che per quanti si
faccia statistica non posso mettere
ordine nel caos che sono io grazie mille
[Applauso]